laughs hard run fast and be kind Peter
Capaldi's era as the doctor we tend to
call him the 12th doctor some people
debate that but his time has come to a
close so that means that finally I'm
able to do a top 10 episodes of Peter
Capaldi's era so that's nice been
waiting on my ability to do that I had
to wait for twice upon a time to err
first just in case it made the list now
um
a quick thing before I get into this
making this list was hard like harder
than usually is when I've done top 10s
for say Tennant and Smith Michaels
tonight only had tend to do in the first
place because a reminder I count two
parters as one story so really is top 10
stories not top 10 episodes but it
really was tough on this one I think
part of what I realized is there are a
lot of performances and moments that I
loved across copales era but a
surprising number of them are in
episodes that I otherwise have a lot of
issues with to pull an example for an
episode that did not make this list
there's like on invasions I got in
version 2 part or that speech in the
Zygon inversion is brilliant it is
wonderfully written perfectly performed
but I also have a lot of problems with
that episode as a whole in terms of
story structure and some mixed themes
that don't quite pan out right and it's
irritating and there's there's a
surprising amount of that and compel
these there are lots of episodes that I
like but maybe didn't have the same
highs but then the ones that have the
really high points also have some low
ones that it's mixing it's a matter of
finding the balance so there are some
episodes that are on this list that if
you'd asked me before I actually sat
down to compile it I would gone now
that's probably not a top 10 episode and
they're on this list anyway so if it was
a weird one this that's enough preamble
let's get into it
number 10 twice upon a time yes I may be
prisoner of the
with this it did just air I did like it
a couple issues but I did enjoy and I
have now recently rewatched it but I do
think personally it's it's my favorite
regeneration story of new who certainly
a prior to this was probably the end of
time but tents eggs is really
self-indulgent and just goes on for a
really long time but here I I love that
the doctor doesn't have something to fix
he thinks he does he's looking for a
problem he's looking for an enemy but
there isn't one and it's almost a
reaffirmation that there is good in the
universe and the universe is worse I
mean it's not always orrible nastazya
with than always encountering and there
were a lot of wonderful notes that went
along with that Mark Gatiss gave a
really touching performance in his
portrayal David Bradley was really good
as the first doctor they managed to
bring back bill in a way that actually
worked for me and didn't completely
undermine her exit you can give Clara a
nice final though and I don't even like
Clara having now watched it a second
time I really do feel it is an
appropriate ending note for his
particular error number nine the pilot
this one had a lot to do it had to
reestablish what the current status quo
of doctor who was in terms of him
working at this university being semi
stranded on earth because he's got this
vault to deal with that NAR doles keep
an eye on him and introduce bill and set
up their dynamic while also telling an
interesting story and it managed to do
all that impressively I have to say I'm
not I really do like Bill as a companion
and I went in expecting to not like her
I didn't like like the little preview
snippets we saw of her I did and I was
annoyed that it was yet another on the
younger side a female companion from the
modern era I'm really sick that template
so when they did that again with her I
was already annoyed I saw the first
glimpses of her I didn't like it but I
got sold on her really immediately I
think her chemistry with Capaldi is
fantastic and it works really
well and also thankfully she has really
good chemistry with Heather which is
kind of key cuz I usually don't go for
the sort of love-at-first-sight thing
and it still kind of stretches it here
but it still feels nice and it works its
way long and there are moments that are
kind of creepy there are homes that are
cool I love the the things that attract
the doctor to bill and you know talking
about how when she hears him talking
about something she doesn't understand
everyone else kind of frowns she smiles
and like I said there was a lot this
episode had to do it juggled all of it
really well and I thought it was a
pretty good story on top of that number
eight the return of doctor Mysterio I've
talked about this one on on a couple of
lists now so I'll try not to dwell on it
too long but short version I understand
why a lot of fans don't particularly
like this one because if you aren't
really into superheroes yeah it kind of
reads a bit out of place or a bit like
well why is this even here but for me
it's just such a spot on sort of a
little bit of a of a poking fun app but
also a little bit of an appreciation of
you know the importance of superheroes
in general and Superman in particular it
really is riffing on Superman and
especially given how badly Superman has
been handled especially in movies in the
past few years I I just I really like
this and again there's a Kapali really
does have wonderful chemistry with a
heck of a lot of people and he has
terrific chemistry with nardole he has
great chemistry with these other
characters with the hero with the
reporter just with pretty much anytime
he's on screen he just brings a really
good stuff out of people and I love the
banter and the snappy feel I love that
has that kind of quick-witted to the
point of no people don't actually talk
like that kind of dialogue which I like
anyway I would rather have the
characters in show speak quicker and
more wittily than anyone could
reasonably come up with in real life I
want that and I got it here and like I
said I like superheroes so I liked this
number seven The Magician's apprentice
and the witch's familiar our first
two-parter on this list and this one
this was this one that had some ups and
downs as it went along but first of all
the cold
this was brilliant with with just that
he the doctor hearing the name Davros
and just the slow close in on him but
the camera just watching his face fall
oh man and as and then you know I
thought when we got into the second have
like it's gotten downhill Vermeer but we
still got some really great parts with
and the moments between Davros and the
doctor really like touching deep moments
and I know some people feel like it got
cheapened because it's like oh it was a
trick the whole time but for me it kind
of worked it it's I still feel it as a
genuine moment I think there probably is
intended to be a genuineness behind that
moment even though Debra's is also using
it to try and accomplish a further end
there's some wonderful hilarious moments
in it as well the only other chair on
Skaro
Missy's awesome in this I'd love I wish
she had kept a pointy stick
I wish the pointy stick had like become
her thing I would have loved that but
there's a ton of terrific banter in here
Missy with Clara is a lot of fun and
there's just like I said some really
stellar moments and I just this nifty
story looking at the the Daleks and
trying to deal with them and dealing
with their creator and what do we do
with this guy I just I really enjoy this
story number 6 extremists extremists
crap I should have checked how to
pronounce that in any case I like this
episode a lot now if you're wondering
why I am dealing with the story in
isolation as opposed to looking at it as
part of a three-part story along with
pyramid at the end of the world in lie
of the land well the reason is in my
mind extremis is kind of a standalone
story yes it leads to the other two but
it also completes its own little thing I
think of it this way I think of it in
terms of the same way of the first
matrix film or the original Star Wars
film yes there was more to pick up and
tell later and after that but it really
is pretty complete story in and of
itself so I feel safe in still dealing
with it
as a single piece which is good because
those other two are not on this list so
I like a lot about this and it it does
something that it's really hard to do
because when you pause it a really a
mystery that is just really crazy
treating like oh it's really hard to
deliver an answer that feels like it
owns up to that so when you say that
there's this one fact there's this one
revelation there's this one piece of
knowledge that basically causes people
to give up and kill themselves no matter
who they are no matter what their
background religious science-based no
matter what that's a hard thing to
actually deliver on and yet this thing
managed to do that it managed to give me
something like okay yeah I could
actually buy that and I love that the
end to me is really triumphant because
even this computer program version of
the doctor it will still throw a wrench
into these guys plans because he is a
good enough recreation of the genuine
article and just that grin that he has
in the very end and it freezes uh-huh
I really love that I think the build-up
on this is a fantastic and I it's
intriguing and the answers are not
disappointing which when you have a
really high level of intrigue is it's
really easy for the answers disappoint
and for me they don't hear number five
flatline pretty straightforward story
would just with just a little extra
twist of the doctor being stuck in the
TARDIS I mean the reason is kind of
wonderfully absurd but it's it's a
pretty standard story otherwise it's
just really well executed
it's a neat idea it's an intriguing idea
these two dimensional beings that they
just uh it's kind of an Irving what it
is they do to people you know the the
way that they move in the special effect
I mean the special effects on Doctor Who
can go either way but when they're
inventive that can make up for it and
that I think that is the case here it's
a really interesting concept I like that
we have this group and the the ones who
survive and the ones who you know what
they do in the group eating doesn't
automatically
expectations I like that a lot it's an
incredibly triumphant moment when the
doctor get the TARDIS gets full-size
again and he just marches I beat
unbuttons of the jackin marches out that
he's gonna defeat the monsters all that
his awesome stuff and again there's
nothing this is one where the concept is
not particularly exciting it's just it's
a very nuts and bolts episode but it's
really well polished nuts and bolts and
it just it just hits number four oxygen
this is one that and when it started the
yeah the very first thing you kind of
see it looks it looks just like neo
space zombies I'm just oh alright I'm
not gonna like this but then as we get
more into what it is that's going on why
it's going on all the funky little
complications in how they have to deal a
bit I really love that I love when
they're the rules are weird and when I
say the rules I mean like the
circumstances and the restrictions and
the things that heroes have to do to get
out of something I like it when they're
a little weird it doesn't allow for a
straightforward solution but it allows
for a more clever solution because the
officer who's you have to deal with are
also kind of like oh god this is what
we're dealing with and I just I love
that approach to to the you know issues
and problems especially in a sci-fi
setting where so much of things I do is
run by computers and and machines that
can have a thought process that is not a
human thought process and I think all
that is executed really well in oxygen
and I just think it is it really digs
into the themes that it's working with
and I think it executes them quite well
and I like that this is this is more for
later episodes but it's worth bringing
up I like that there were lasting
consequences to the fact that the doctor
went blind I mean how often does that
happen
cool stuff number three the world enough
in time and the doctor Falls I wanted to
break this one up and justify dealing
with each one individually like I deal
with extremists taking
out of that three parter but I can't the
story isn't really complete at the end
of world enough and time and too many
things are left hanging it it is a
genuine two-parter I do need to treat it
all as one story which is a little bit
unfortunate now they both would have
made the list even individually dr.
Falls would have been a little lower
world it up in time by itself would have
had a shot at possibly even the top spy
it would have been close but lumping
them together it comes in at three I've
talked about world enough in time before
but it is an awesome wonderful creepy
episode I love how it really digs into
what is unnerving on the conceptual
level about the Cybermen not like as an
army as a force but like the ideas
behind what it is they are and why those
are unnerving ideas and concepts I love
how much it digs into that I love a mr.
razor in that in that first part what is
revealed to be the master I was kinda
like oh okay but like mr. razor as a
character I dug along thought was neat
thought was interesting and against so
many creepy moments and then when we get
into the second half things we can a
little bit I've said in the past I John
seems quite good in this but I'm not
entirely sure how necessary it was to
have it be a to master story it feels
that feels a little gimmicky and because
that feels like the sort of thing that
should be driving the narrative a little
bit more than it is in this particular
case that said a lot of great moments
bill talking with the doctor the fact
that the doctor can't fix her even
though he said that he could and he
believed it when he said it but he still
can't his pleading would the master just
be kind which I think you know it's
funny that for a doctor that I think for
a while some of us were thinking his
trademark phrase was going to be shut up
he kind of ended on the recurring idea
of just be kind and I think that's his
legacy more than anything else and it's
one of the things I've really loved
about Capaldi is that he started out so
harsh ended so kind and more than any
other doctor that that I can think of he
really had a character journey at a
character arc across his time and I love
where he ends up in this episode leading
into twice a lot of time which I've
already talked about number two mummy on
the Orient Express a title that sounds
like this should be the most ridiculous
stupid thing ever and it's just awesome
this has almost everything I love in a
terrific Doctor Who episode a cool
setting a phenomenal supporting cast
both the actors and the characters
they're playing they're interesting
they're compelling the way they work
their dynamics their interactions it's
all interesting and we're seeing which
makes you care about them when they come
in jeopardy the the situation is weird
and bizarre and and in a way that here's
the thing normally I get iffy whenever
Doctor Who tackles what is kind of a
more traditional supernatural foe you
know vampires ghosts werewolves
what-have-you because I'm like well it's
it's not what it looks like it's
something else but just the but just the
fact that this is already on a train in
space and like okay
you've given it the side that's really
the only added sci-fi bit I need if this
had been set on earth and like oh it's a
mummy I would have been like oh come on
but it's like wait a minute what's a
mummy doing in space I'm so into this
it's a minor tweak but for me it makes a
big difference and again just the the
doctor and his excitement in his
intensity trying to work on this trying
to figure out this problem and it's the
timer and the clock and the ticking down
and that is it's properly timed and
going in real time all just phenomenal
wonderful tense just terrific episode my
number one episode heaven-sent oh wow
okay this episode is one of the most
enjoyable emotional roller coasters I've
ever gotten in entertainment forget
Doctor Who I mean at all from a movie
from a TV show from a video game
the the emotional rollercoaster and how
condensed it was and I'm gonna kind of
come back to that but everything from
the set up I love that it is a single
location story but that doesn't feel
small that it feels expansive even
though it's kind of a bottle episode but
it's kinda not
I love these talking to himself I love
that he sort of goes into his mind
powers in and he says always assume I
know how to get out of this can't wait
to see how I figure it out and I just
him going through and that the
creepiness of the thing that stalking
him is really cool and trying to figure
it out along with him what is going on
what's going on with this and then at
the end realizing what's happening and
see him start the loop again and then
see him start the loop again and again
and again and when I talked about that
emotional roller coaster this this
episode took me from a deep emotional
sinking oh dear God what am i watching
to such a joyous triumph so the low
point is just seeing the loop start to
play over and over and over again and
going oh my god how long is this going
to go on is completely hopeless it is
pointless and like it does it's it's
perfectly time to because it doesn't
quite give you enough time to think how
could he get out of this maybe give you
enough time think is someone gonna
rescue him but that's that's right when
I noticed he's getting a little farther
in that bird story every time and then
it's like he's telling mobster oh my god
and realizing why he was getting further
in the story as he slowly chips away at
this wall and just but absolute
rocketing of emotions going from such a
low place to such a yes
triumphant of him breaking through that
thing it was amazing it was such an
emotional journey and enough and like
the peak and valley of it in such a
confined space it is masterful and it is
a surprisingly insightful look at grief
and trying to process grief on top of
all of that and if you're wondering why
this is in isolation by itself and I'm
not attaching it to hell-bent
as a two-parter it's because it is a
very seconds a story it ends at a point
that yes hell-bent as has to pick that
up and run with it but in terms of the
story it was telling it was the story of
him trapped in this castle that story is
finished I consider it a standalone
piece that simply leaves in place what
the next story is going to start from
but it's not a two-parter it is however
a truly glorious episode of television
and my personal pick for the best
episode of Peter Capaldi's run as the
doctor that's my list what's yours
whatever it is drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it do all
the stuff like subscribe I'm on Twitter
and then that podcasts and stuff there's
links for all that stuff below and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]